JUSTICES THAT ARE TRYING TO BE
CONFIRMED.
FIRST, WE GO BACK TO THE CRISIS
ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE H.S. SECRETARY, KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN, RELEASED A STATEMENT
YESTERDAY SAYING THE MIGRANT
CARAVAN IS FAR LARGER, MORE
ORGANIZED THAN PREVIOUS ONCE.
EARLIER, I SAT DOWN WITH THE
SECRETARY TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
SO MUCH MORE.
>> MADAM SECRETARY, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> LET'S TALK FIRST ABOUT THE
WEEKEND.
LET ME QUOTE ONE BORDER PATROL
CHIEF, CAR THAT CARLA PROVOST.
OUR AGENTS WERE RUSHED AND THEY
WERE THROWING ROCKS AND BOTTLES
AT MY MEN AND WOMEN PUTTING THEM
IN HARM'S WAY.
HOW BAD WAS IT?
>> SEAN, LET ME JUST SAY, THIS
IS A TESTAMENT TO THE TRAINING
AND PROFESSIONALISM OF THE
BORDER PATROL THAT NO ONE WAS
HURT.
WE HAD 1,000 PEOPLE RUSHING THE
BORDER IN A VERY VIOLENT AND
LAWLESS WAY.
WE WILL NOT STAND BY AS OUR
BORDER PATROL ARE ATTACKED.
SO THEY DEFENDED THEMSELVES.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE ANY
CHOICE.
THE THING IS, WE SEE NOW THAT
THE MAYOR INTERESTINGLY OF
TIJUANA SAID, EXCUSE ME, TRUMP
WAS RIGHT.
THIS IS AN INVASION.
THEY HAVE NOW HAD A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE HAD TO
DEAL WITH.
THE MIGRANTS, THE CARAVAN ARE
STILL COMING.
THEY ARE COMING IN BIGGER
NUMBERS.
WHAT IF LARGER NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
RUSH THE BORDER, ARE YOU
CONFIDENT YOU ARE PREPARED?
>> WE WERE PREPARED THIS TIME.
WE WILL BE PREPARED FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL MIGRANTS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE IT QUITE
CLEAR.
WE WILL NOT TOLERATE ILLEGAL OR
VIOLENT ENTRY INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THIS TIME, HE TALKED ABOUT IT
FOR A MONTH IN ADVANCE AS THE
CARAVANS WERE MAKING THEIR WAY
UP.
HE RAISED AWARENESS.
HE CALLED IN THE MILITARY.
HE CALLED IN CON STAN STEIN
WIRE.
WE WILL BE PREPARED.
WE WILL NOT ALLOW ILLEGAL ENTRY
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
>> ONE THING THE PRESIDENT SAID,
IF THEY ARE GOING TO BE SEEKING
ASYLUM, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
IN THIS COUNTRY OR ALLOWED IN
THIS COUNTRY WHILE WHATEVER
PROCESS GOES FORWARD.
ONE OF THE PROBLEM HAS BEEN,
PEOPLE CROSS THE BORDER, CLAIM
ASYLUM, GET A COURT DATE, THEY
ARE RELEASED INTO AMERICA AND
THEY NEVER SHOW UP AGAIN.
HOW INSISTENT IS THE PRESIDENT
THAT THEY STAY IN MEXICO?
HOW ARE RELATIONS WITH MEXICO
CONSIDERING THEY WERE TOLD A
LONG TIME AGO THEY SHOULD BE
DEALING WITH THIS?
>> THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POINT
YOU RAISED, SEAN.
WE ONLY SEE ABOUT 9%, 10% OF
CENTRAL AMERICANS THAT MAKE AN
ASYLUM CLAIM ACTUALLY BE GRANTED
ASYLUM BY AN IMMIGRATION JUDGE.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO PUT
IN PERSPECTIVE.
90% OF THOSE MAKING ASYLUM
CLAIMS ARE NOT MAKING THE CLAIM
THAT CAN BE HONORED UNDER THE
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES, NOT A VALID
REASON FOR ASYLUM.
YOU HAVE HEARD ME SAY IT BEFORE.
IF YOU ARE COMING TO GET A JOB,
THAT'S NOT A CLAIM FOR ASYLUM.
IF YOU ARE COMING TO BE WITH
YOUR FAMILY, THAT'S NOT A CLAIM
FOR ASYLUM.
>> ISN'T IT LIKELY THEY ARE
GOING TO BE COACHED?
IF THEY WANT ASYLUM, DIDN'T
MEXICO OFFER THEM WORK PERMITS
TO WORK IN SOUTH MEXICO.
THAT WAS REJECTED BY MOST.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE
REMAINING CARAVAN STILL MAKING
ITS WAY NORTH?
>> WE BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
ABOUT 10,000 ULTIMATELY.
THERE IS BETWEEN 8,000 AND
10,000 NOW.
THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO OFFERED
EVERYONE ASYLUM AND WORK
PERMITS.
THAT'S WHY THIS CARAVAN IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN ONES WE HAVE SEEN
IN THE PAST.
NOT ONLY IS IT VIOLENT.
TO THE EXTENT IT CLAIMS THAT ITS
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO SEEK
ASYLUM.
THEY HAVE BEEN OFFERED ASYLUM.
THEY HAVE TURNED IT DOWN IN
MEXICO.
>> LET ME PLAY A SHOT FROM 60
MINUTES, SCOTT PELLE.
THE ARGUMENT WAS ABOUT THE
SEPARATION ISSUES AND HOW THERE
WAS A WARRANT FOR ONE
3-YEAR-OLD.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED OUT, AND
WE HAVE IMAGES OF EVEN YOUNG
PEOPLE, WHEN OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT, THAT ARE BEHIND
FENCES.
THEY WOULD SAY IT IS CAGES IF IT
WAS DONALD TRUMP.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION MADE
THE DECISION TO SEPARATE
CHILDREN FROM FAMILIES.
WHAT RESPONSIBILITIES DID THEY
TAKE ON IN YOUR ESTIMATION?
>> THEY ISSUED AN ORDER WITHOUT
CONSULTING WITH THE AGENCIES WHO
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR CARRYING
OUT THAT ORDER.
WE TAKE BETTER CARE OF PEOPLE'S
EFFECTS WHEN WE SEND THEM TO THE
JAIL THAN WE TOOK CARE OF THE
CHILDREN WHO WE TOOK FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
>> YOU QUIT YOUR JOB AT HOMELAND
SECURITY.
I WONDER WHY.
>> I HAD TAKEN AN OATH TO UPHOLD
THE CONSTITUTION.
WE WERE BEING ASKED AS A
DEPARTMENT TO DO SOMETHING THAT
VIOLATED THE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES OF PERSONS.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION.
WASN'T IT PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
STOPPED THE PRACTICE THROUGH AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER?
>> SEAN, IT WAS.
I AM SO DISAPPOINTED IN THAT
PIECE.
THAT IS JOURNALIST.
THAT'S NOT JOURNALIST.
THAT'S FACTUALLY INCORRECT.
WE DID NOT HAVE A POLICY TO
SEPARATE FAMILIES FROM THE
CHILDREN.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID AND ALL
PRESIDENTS BEFORE HIM, WE ARE
FIRST LAW.
THIS PRESIDENT TAKES IT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
WE ENFORCED THE LAW AGAINST
THOSE THAT CHOSE TONE TER
ILLEGALLY, NOT GO LEGALLY TO A
PORT OF ENTRY BUT ENTER
ILLEGALLY.
THEY WERE PROSECUTED.
BECAUSE OF THAT, IF THEY HAD
CHILDREN WITH THEM, SO AS NOT TO
PUT CHILDREN IN A CUSTODIAL
JAIL, THEY WERE SEPARATED AND
PUT IN THE GOOD CARE OF HHS.